ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري واستراتيجي سيد اللواء
ونحن نتابع الطرفين كل جهه تعتقد انها
الان احرزت يعني نقطه في مرماها همم
الاوكرانيين يحصلون على بطاريه من
البيتروت
والروس سي يوظفون كل ما لديهم ملك
الصواريخ كما يسمونه همم
دي مواجهه اي تقدم عسكري من الجانب الاخر
يعني كيف يضع هذا همم موضوع الحرب الان
الدائره على الارض اين نحن
يعني يعني الان هذا يعني فتح افاق ايه او
الافق الزمني
لاستمرار هذه الحرب وبالتالي رصد 45 مليار
من قبل الاداره الامريكيه
يعلي لعام 2023 يعني ان عام 2023 ضمن
الاطار الزمني وبالتالي هذه الحرب طويله
ومستمره ومكلفه خطاب الرئيس الروسي تقريبا
كان موجه الى القوات المسلحه الروسيه الى
اوكرانيا الى الغرب تحدث عن امور تخص
القوات الروسيه كشفت جوانب ضعف في الاذاعه
الميداني وفتحت افاق
للتفاؤل وتطوير القدرات عندما يتحدث عن
الصواريخ الفرد الصوتيه الثالوث
الاستراتيجي توظيف الطائرات المسيره توظيف
الذكاء الاصطناعي همم تطوير القدرات ال-
ال- الامداد لوجستي والعمليات اذا هي
رسائل متعدده لكن قابلها بالمقابل
تجامن زياره رئيس جريزكي في يوم خطاب
الرئيس بوتن وهذه لها دلالتها الرمزيه
الحديث عن باتريوت تم اعطاءه مساءا كبيره
جدا انا اقول منصه واحده لن تغير الكثير
قد تستخدم للدفاع عن كيف لن تغير في
الامور بصوره كبيره لن تستخدم ضد الطائرات
المسيره بسبب كلفه الصواريخ ولكن اهميه
هذا القرار ياتي من كسر قاعده الخطوط
الحمراء كان صواريخ باتريوت
دبابات ابرامز الطائرات المجنحه
يمارس 300 كيلو متر صواريخ 165 كيلومتر
تقع خلف الخط الاحمر الان تم كسر هذا الخط
بالموافقه على صواريخ باتريات ولو بطاريه
وانت اشرت الى ممكن وصول بطاريات لاحقا
اذا دعيني اقول الموافقه على باتريوت قد
تعني الموافقه على همارس 300 اي قذف داخل
الروسي قصف جزيره القرم قد يعنى الموافقه
على طائرات اف 16 مستقبلا وتقريبا ثلاثه
او امور مترابطه متزامنه
باتريوت ابرامز
وطائرات اف 16 هذا ما كان يطالب به الرئيس
رزقي الان حصل على الطلب الاول ما يمنع ان
يحصل على طلب الثاني والثالث اشكرك فايز
الدويري خبير العسكري من عمان شكرا